هي اول مره انططاوا فيها قدماه ولايه
فلوريدا منذ الكشف عن لائحه الاتهام التي
ستوجه اليه والمتعلقه بقضيه الوثائق
السريه التي استحوذ عليها دون حق كما تقول
الحكومه الفتراليه
محاطا بالعشرات من انصاره عبر موكب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى نادي
للجولف يملكه في ضواحي ميامي قبل توجهه
اليوم الى المحكمه لتتلى عليه التهم ويدفع
هو ببراءته كما اعلن ترامب يواجه 37 تهمه
تراوح عقوبتها القصوى بين عشره اعوام
وعشرين
قام بالشيء نفسه على الملا ولم يواجهها اي
تداعيات دونالد ترامب يتقدم في استطلاعات
الراي ويبدو انهم يئسوا من هزيمته عبر
صناديق الاقتراع
هنا في هذه المحكمه الفيدراليه ستتلى على
ترامب لائحه الاتهام السلطات الامنيه تكثف
من استعدادها وفرق وسائل الاعلام تتخذ
مواقعها واستمر خوف من تظاهرات دعت اليها
جماعات يمينيه متشدده مناصره
واحتمالات اندلاع اعمال شغب تتحسب لها
السلطات
في مدينه نؤمن بالدستور ونعتقد انه يجب ان
يكون للناس الحق في التعبير عن انفسهم
لكننا نؤمن ايضا بالقانون والنظام نامل ان
تكون التجمعات السلميه ونشجع الناس على
ذلك سنخصص القوات الكافيه للتاكد من ذلك
من المرشح ان يتم اغلاق بعض الشوارع في
المدينه ما قد يتسبب في ازدحام حركه
المرور مستعدون لاي حشود بغض النظر عن
حجمها ترقب مشروب بحذر وسط استعدادات
امنيه قبيل ساعات من مثول ترامب امام هذه
المحكمه في ميامي ليكون رسميا اول رئيس
امريكي سابق يخضع لمحاكمه جنائيه فيدراليه
عقوبتها القصوى قد تضعه في حاله الادانه
خلف القضبان لعشرين عاما احمد هزيم
الجزيره ميامي